[Musique]
aujourd'hui on parle graffiti et urbex
urbex c'est le raccourci anglais pour
exploration urbaine une pratique en
plein essor qui consiste à visiter des
lieux des constructions à l'abandon et
avant même que le terme urbex existe les
graffeurs explorait déjà toutes sortes
de friches à la recherche d' espaces
vierges à peindre c'est le cas de m cl
un artiste or les années que nous avons
rencontrés et qui se présente comme un
exploit graffeurs il y a plus de 20 ans
il inscrivait son pseudo sur les
palissades des voies rapides de
l'agglomération orléanaise de long des
voies ferrées
depuis les terrains de jeu de m6 ils
sont à l'écart des lieux à l'abandon
oublié par tous ou presque où il aime
laisser une trace de son passage urbex
le terme a fait florès exploration
urbaine mais aussi souvent rurales
c'était un peu du coin on a beaucoup de
fermes aux sikhs ont été abandonnées une
époque et on peut s'apercevoir reste du
temps après au bout de quelques années
en effet en a de plus en plus de ce
genre de lieu dans le coin y'a pas que
les châteaux dans la région on a aussi
pas mal de firmes
son goût pour l'exploration m cl le
partage sur une page instagram suivi par
près d'un millier d'abonnés pour
observer les effets du temps voir la
nature reprendre ses droits
ils visitent des centaines de sites
désaffectés dans la région et dans toute
la france quelque part dans le loiret
une ancienne usine est devenue sa
galerie privée dans une des pièces
il a travaillé l'anamorphose le terme
plus générique ça serait trompe l'oeil
que vous se fondre dans le décor en fait
faire quelque chose d'un peu près
réaliste et pour couvrir les murs de
cette vaste salle il n'a pas compté les
heures passées à atteindre les week-ends
et jours fériés
c'était une des plus grandes les murs
étaient sympa j'aime bien travailler sur
le mur brut pour besoin de passer une
couche de peinture avant genre de choses
et c'est cela qui a peu qui sait que
c'était le mieux au jeu c'est un esprit
assez zen et je vais dans un endroit zen
je me sens bien dans ce genre de lieu
c'est un peu un havre de paix un havre
de paix dont il ne restera bientôt plus
que des photos car des travaux vont
bientôt débuter sur le site sommes
toujours avec m cl pour par les
graffitis et urbex m cl urbex c'est un
terme récent mais la pratique est plus
ancienne tout à fait vrai donc le rex
pour urban exploration en anglais qui a
commencé en france des années 80 qui se
fait de plus en plus depuis deux trois
ans grâce aux réseaux sociaux
c'est devenu un peu la mode en effet
c'est à dire tu as pu croiser du monde
du monde est de plus en plus de monde
certains lieux qui sont devenus
tellement connue il est tellement
partager des personnes qui connaissent
pas vraiment qu'il ya des lieux où tu
vas très tôt le matin il ya déjà des
landes sur place donc c'est pour un truc
qui est censé être une sorte de havre de
paix visitez le passé avoir une certaine
tranquillité tu le plus la tranquillité
alors c'est une pratique qui peut être
aussi risqué d'abord d'un point de vue
légal c'est pas toujours autorisé c'est
alors assez spécial une zone d'ombré à
dire il ya un vide juridique sur le
sujet quand le lieu est ouvert et plus
ou moins abandonnée en faux frais c'est
comment dire faut trouver certains
indices comme quoi le le lieu est à
bourdonner on voit la nature qui
repousse
il ya plein dans un esprit vif et qu'on
devine que les abandonner mais faut
faire attention à ce genre de choses
donc par rapport à ça si le lieu est
ouvert que l'on rentre juste pour
prendre des photos a priori il n'y a pas
trop de risques donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut faire attention vraiment à pas
dégradée ne pas faire d ouverture de ce
lieu sinon là on rentre
franchement dans l'illégalité en dehors
de ça il ya une tolérance
on peut dire ça c'est plus un vide
juridique sur le sujet il ya d'autres
types de risques
il y a eu lieu voilà quels sont-ils
quelles précautions il faut placer plus
sécurité il ya des endroits où c'est
devenu tellement bon et depuis tellement
longtemps donc très fragile
on ne peut passer à travers le plancher
lequel toit s'écroule
ces niveaux sécurité oui ça peut être
très dangereux vaut mieux éviter d'être
seul par exemple ça serait pas mal déjà
comme ça si jamais un blessé sur les là
où les deux personnes une des deux peut
prévenir les secours
c'est plus que conseillé du coup voilà
des précautions importantes a rappelé
merci beaucoup m cl c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve demain
toujours avec des graffeurs mais qui
sont passés eux à la toile ou à la
sculpture à demain